this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 23. sitting here with again with
Echo Charles Echo Charlie as they say
sure
I wanted to talk speaking of speaking of
laughing and just chuckling about stuff
I want to talk about a different kind of
emotion that we sometimes feel
frustration
anger or annoyance
frustration
the definition of frustration is anger
or annoyance
by your own
inability
to either achieve something or change
something
that's what frustration is
again I've I've started to pay attention
to when I'm talking to clients when I'm
dealing with people I'm starting to pay
attention to
what's happening to them you know the
last one we talked about
balance and I see when I
deal with people and I talk to people
when I coach people through certain
situations I see them getting out of
balance is a
it it trips people up or jams people up
as you know as you like to say
uh this is another one people get
frustrated what's what's interesting
about the frustration is look you can
get frustrated with people for sure but
you can also get frustrated with
inanimate objects I know that the
running joke in my family is that I get
frustrated with uh
printers printers number one or whatever
but it's it's all kind of in ingest
so
but when I see when I see it impacting
people
and I just wanted to talk a little bit
about it so we can look at what do we do
with it right it's a thing it's a real
thing
we have to utilize it
actually
um one thing that we realized when we
get frustrated you're not going to do
any better by allowing the frustration
to to impact the way you're behaving
doesn't help the anger
that you're feeling the frustration that
you're feeling is not going to help you
get any smoother it's not going to help
you get any better it's not going to
help you overcome that problem it's not
going to help you interact with that
person so you can change their mind
all those things are bad
all those things are bad
so we can't allow this to impact us we
have to we we have to contend with what
we've got we got to work with it so
I I would say one of the uh
I started getting frustrated the other
day
sure dang sorry yeah I started getting
frustrated the other day what happened
was and the reason I want to talk about
this is because I started getting
frustrated then I this is how I over I'm
going to talk about how I overcame the
frustration I was
was had a late night
I
was up too late
I had actually decided like okay you
know what
it's 1 30 in the morning right now I'm
not gonna get up at 4 30. I'm gonna you
know sleep until whatever probably six
so I did that
so got up at six
and which is pretty rare for me but look
if you're gonna get three hours of sleep
that's a negative that's it's not that's
not a good move right you may have to at
some point but it wasn't a good wouldn't
have been a good move in this situation
sleep until six cool
so I sleep until 6 6 15 something like
this get up get out of bed put my
workout gear on well what's interesting
is now at six o'clock in the morning I'm
not alone in the house right my wife's
downstairs so now when I go downstairs
I'm ready to work out but you know my
wife's gonna be saying hi you know going
through the the morning procedures of
hello and as as you and I talked about
on the Last underground
um you know we have to
remember that relationships are part of
the path so hey my wife's kind of stoked
that I'm talking to her it's early in
the morning she's up I'm up you know so
what do I do I spend 15 minutes talking
about whatever things you know we're
hanging out for a little bit cool
so now it's probably more than 20
minutes so now it's like pushing 645 7
o'clock right
but now I get up to the garage gym
and
I
chalk up it's pull-up day so I'm gonna
be doing pull-ups I'm doing muscle ups
so I start my my warm-up routine
stretching a little warm-up routine I'm
doing a couple I hang on the bar for a
little bit then I do like a one pull up
two pull-ups I'm I'm to like my first
warm-up set um so it's been 10 minutes
no maybe not 10 minutes it's been five
minutes
in rolls my son to the gym so normally
I'm done that's kind of our little
Unwritten rule I've got until seven you
know right you know so I'm up at 4 30
I'm in the gym by five you know I'm
working out doing whatever stretching
get done by seven hope you know all
things normal I'm done he's in there and
he's not alone because he's got his his
little crew that he lives with and
trains with
well they come rolling and they're
already
they have already been working out so
they went for a run or something they
went up to the track and did Sprint so
now they're back now they're there to
finish off leg day by the way so
uh you know he's like are you almost
done
but he's kind of looking at me with a
tilted head because he sees that I'm not
dripping with sweat so he's like are you
are you almost done and I go no I
you know I just started
and he goes well
he's like can can we work out first can
we work out right now and I'm like what
do you have because I figured if they're
doing something maybe they're doing
kettlebells we could kind of get it done
I could use the pole bar he's like
squats
and I go
now meanwhile I knew I had some editing
to do like just I'm just gonna do a
quick edit on something for Echelon
front I was like cool
and I had text relief and he's like hey
can you take a look at this I'm like yep
absolutely so I go you know what I'm
gonna go you know I said hey go ahead
how long you need he's like an hour this
is my son an hour I said cool
so
he's
he goes and starts
um he's working out so I figured you
know what I'm gonna go take a look at
this document that they've sent me so I
go start going through that and all of a
sudden well as I'm doing that I get
another I get Jamie sends me so hey can
you take a look at this so I'm like okay
so now I'm editing now I was just gonna
edit it short now I'm looking at a
longer document and now there's a couple
sections that are highlighted for me to
look at but as I change one of them I'm
not gonna go now all of a sudden I'm
rewriting stuff instead of just editing
but I at the mo this is where the
frustration came in so now I'm kind of
pissed that I haven't worked out yet and
oh yeah and like also I had a phone call
not a scheduled phone call but like an
unscheduled phone call that was not an
emergency but a scenario that needed to
be dealt with so now I'm talking through
this for 38 minutes or whatever
so because I was thinking look I'll
still be able to get just jumped out in
the gym but whatever so
so now I realize I got more work to do
and as I realized that as I look at this
document
that I'm gonna have to rewrite some
stuff and it's not just an edit but it's
a rewrite I have a moment of like damn
it
like damn it like I
I didn't sign up for this today right I
had plans right and there's a
frustration left right right this this
is one it was not what I was yeah this
was not on the agenda right so I have
this little bit of frustration creeps up
and look I don't get frustrated very
easily but I had just a little bit
because now I'm missing a workout I was
uh well still even though I even though
I woke up a little later I still was
only operating on like four and a half
five hours worth of sleep so I'm I'm
that I'm frustrated about that I'm
frustrated about my son being in the gym
when I should be in there I mean I had
chalk on my hands like there's a certain
protocol in the world that shouldn't be
violated and it was and now this
document that I was gonna you know you
think oh can you take a look at this
document cool you're thinking four seven
maybe ten minutes now I'm starting to
now I'm looking I gotta rewrite stuff so
the frustration level starts to escalate
and as soon as I felt that I was like
cool you know what boom get to work
that's that's literally what I said I
said you know what get to work I just
let that frustration just let it go man
and I got to work that's my point
is that frustration
can really end up being more of a
distraction than anything else where you
start getting frustrated about something
and it's making you mad and it turns
more it turns whatever you're doing
worse makes whatever you're doing worse
you want to hear a funny story yeah so
Leif Babin and I sure we are at the
muster in New York City
and again this was our second muster
it's our first muster out in New York
City
there's
things happened we failed to plan
certain things we didn't do things
in the smoothest possible way we
underestimated the time it would take
for things there's a bunch of mistakes
that we made that we worked had to deal
with and by the way there's
the muster starts at 4 45 in the morning
for the for the attendees and it ends at
you know six o'clock at night day one
and it's the same thing on day two
that's what the attendees are going to
see right when you're at when someone
attends the monster that's what they're
gonna see
they don't see what happens in the hours
in between those things but but at this
particular monster the New York was the
worst muster from a logistic standpoint
for a whole bunch of different a whole
bunch of reasons all of which are on me
because you know we're running the
mustard Echelon front and so when things
aren't right there's only one person to
play
but that's where we're at so one of the
things we have to do is sign
certificates of graduation right like
hey
everyone's going so we're so for
whatever multitude of reasons
it's
it's like one o'clock in the morning two
I think it's actually I think it's
actually two o'clock in the morning we
are gonna go PT at 3 30 in the morning
yeah and Leif and I have got a stack of
850 there's 850 I think attendees at the
muster and we've got a sign 850 of these
certificates everyone else is asleep so
it's sometimes it makes it I know it
might sound diva-ish but if you have to
sign a bunch of stuff and someone's
helping you it makes it a lot easier
right there's someone put in front of
you to someone taken away and passing it
to life and so we can get it done in one
third of the time yeah if you have
someone helping you because think about
it you gotta the things are sticking
together it makes sense so so we start
signing these things
so I'm just signed I'm I'm just signing
a boom boom boom and and life he starts
going some of these are
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Ninjago underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we
mobilized
Underground